we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p here is an empowering
message for populism directed at pat
take a listen to this hi david impact
david i think you need to be a lot nicer
to pat because I think he's really
extending your audience because there's
some people who the boudoir French press
coffee appeals to but the Keurig is the
coffee of the people and you know Pat is
representing the people solution you
should really you know embrace his you
know his popular ISM that's all yeah
popularize him I guess not populism
listen here's the thing it's all
wonderful and with peace and love
send your warm wishes to Pat and all
that stuff this voicemail is BS and I
will tell you why a French press costs
ten dollars okay where is the cure it
costs depending on which model you get
eighty ninety or over a hundred dollars
number one hold on a second number two
when you look at the per pound cost of
coffee in Keurig pods it is drastically
higher than what it costs to just buy
regular old coffee beans for a French
press so given that both the device and
the coffee are cheaper with a French
press than with a Keurig how is the
Keurig the populous choice for coffee
but you're forgetting that I use the
reusable coffee pods and I understand
that you're trying to backtrack from
your more elitist methods it's not gonna
work here so but how do you explain that
how is a $90 Keurig machine popular
populist over a ten dollar French press
I think you're making this up this is
all fake news yeah exactly so listen
there's nothing more populist than a ten
dollar French press
all right that's let's keep that let's
not forget that on the bonus show today
the anti-abortion activists who secretly
filmed Planned Parenthood have been
charged with not one not two not three
not four not five not six or seven but
15 felonies we will also talk about what
are now known as can you hear me scams
over the phone and calls are
intensifying for Bill O'Reilly to be
fired
for his comments about Maxine Waters not
gonna happen but we will talk about it
on the bonus show sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code is still available I voted 17 will
speak to you then